all right everybody there has been a lot
of talk about The Avengers for trailer
release date Marvel Studios has kept a
very tight lid on everything concerning
Avengers 4 including when we're going to
see the first trailer and the title but
today we finally have a little bit of
clarity about when we're going to see
that first Avengers 4 trailer my
giveaway still continues for a few more
days I'm giving away copies of infinity
war and ant-man and the wasp on blu-ray
and some special edition posters all you
have to do to enter for your chance to
win is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
I'll be picking another winner again
this weekend so last night October 25th
there was a special screening of Black
Panther for potential Oscar voters and
those in attendance actually got to ask
some questions and luckily for us one of
those questions was when does the
Avengers 4 trailer come out and Kevin
Feige answered in 2018 his actual answer
was before the end of the year so we
know that we're going to get it this
year that is huge great news because
there's been a rumor going around right
now that it was actually going to show
when Captain Marvel premiered and
although that was extremely unlikely
seeing as how Captain Marvel comes out
just a couple of months not even before
Avengers 4 fans were still worried that
we weren't going to see the trailer or
figure out the title until 2019 but
thankfully it's this year and it could
come at any given time it's widely
speculated that it could come November
29th which would mark the one-year mark
since the first Avengers infinity war
trailer was shown there's also the
possibility that it could air with other
big Disney movies that are coming out
very soon Ralph breaks the internet
comes out November 21st spider-man into
the spider verse comes out December 14th
and Mary Poppins Returns comes out on
December 19th if they do it with any of
these it's most likely going to be
spider-man into the spider verse because
the majority of the viewers will be
spider-man fans and Avengers and Marvel
fans but it could drop at any point in
time between now and the end of the year
so be on the lookout so that's it for
this quick update let me know what you
think about this great news that
we're going to get the Avengers 4
trailer before the end of the year leave
your thoughts in the comments below and
don't forget to subscribe comment and
like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date with
everything relating to Avengers 4 thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]